well brian as for vaccinations there is
now a third vaccine soon to be added to
the mix
the fda issued an emergency use for the
johnson and johnson vaccine over the
weekend
joe mohler is live at the las vegas
convention center with more on when we
could expect to see those doses
joe soon people will be heading to
vaccination clinics and sites like the
convention center here and they'll get
one shot and they're done
24 thousand johnson and johnson copen 19
vaccines will be sent to nevada this
week
health health experts say this is a game
changer
now we have three different vaccines
that are very highly effective
starting this week vaccination sites and
clinics will begin administering the
johnson and johnson vaccine johnson
johnson covered vaccine
it doesn't have to be stored in freezing
temperatures it can be stored in room
in a refrigerator for three months the
other major difference it is a single
dose vaccine unlike moderna and pfizer
which requires people to return for a
second dose weeks later
that they're going to re release 4
million doses
this week that means 4 million americans
will be fully vaccinated
which will add to the 50 million that's
already been vaccinated
least with one dose during a statewide
update monday health officials said
nevada will get 24
000 doses this week so far roughly 14
percent of the state has at least one
shot done
a third vaccine offers more options to
the public and medical experts
and are encouraging people to get
whatever vaccine is available to them
the johnson and johnson vaccine
allocation will be in addition to the
moderna and pfizer vaccines
last week 48 thousand doses were on hand
in clark county
health officials have said in clark
county they have the capacity to
administer
90 000 a week it's great news that we
have a third product to sort of build
and increase what our weekly allocation
is
now back out here live out of those 24
000 vaccines that are
that are being sent to nevada they will
be dispersed based on population we did
reach out to clark county officials
today to see
how many might be heading here but they
did not have a number yet reporting live
here at the convention center joe mohler
8 news now